[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today string theory
our universe contains mata which when we
look closer is made up
of particles there are different types
of particles
electrons quarks or neutrinos
particles move in the universe and can
interact by exchanging
other particles the electromagnetic
force for example
is mediated by the exchange of photons
all these different particles are
accounted for in what we call
the standard model it is currently our
most precise mathematical description
of the quantum world it contains two
main categories of particles
fermions which mostly constitute matter
and bosons which mostly describe
interactions
at first glance one might think that
this is the
ultimate theory that the standard model
describes
everything but unfortunately there is
another
interaction that this model doesn't
account for
gravity on a large scale
we know that gravity is described by
general relativity
objects curve space-time thus attracting
other objects
as with other types of interactions we
expect that the curvature of space-time
is made up of small particles at the
quantum scale
quanta of space-time curvature called
gravitons
[Music]
but when we try to include the graviton
in the standard model
the calculations give absurd results
with infinite values
that cannot be removed we cannot
describe
gravity on the quantum scale
it is to solve this problem that
physicists have been looking for new
theories
for more than half a century in this
video
we are going to build together one of
the most promising approaches
string theory
[Music]
the basic idea is quite simple
in the standard model particles are
described as small dimensionless points
we admit that these points do not all
have the same properties
to account for the fact that there are
different types of particles
in string theory we will assume that
this is only an approximation
and that if we zoom in on the particles
they are all made up of a small string
sometimes open and sometimes closed
these little strings have tension like
tiny rubber bands
and they can vibrate
a guitar string can vibrate in different
modes
harmonics
likewise our little strings can vibrate
in different ways
one ripple two ripples three ripples
and so on and the different vibrating
modes behave on
our scale like particles of different
types
when we perform the calculations we
discover in particular that some strings
behave like photons
[Music]
and better still some like gravitons
starting from the sole principle that
particles are tiny strings with tension
we already explain why there are
different types of particles
[Music]
and we naturally predict the existence
of the graviton
thus describing gravity at the quantum
scale
we now want to understand how these
strings evolve through the universe
for that we will use the same principles
as our current models
imagine that we throw an electron at a
target
the electron propagates like a wave and
when it reaches the target
we can't know for sure where it will
materialize
at the quantum scale the same experiment
can give different results
we can only predict the probability of
observing such or such results
and the goal of physics at this scale is
to determine
these probabilities
[Music]
the mathematical approach to determine
the probability of observing a
particular result
is to consider all possible scenarios
that lead to it
at the same time we sum
all trajectories but also all possible
interactions
for example an electron can emit a
photon then reabsorb it
or two photons or even three
in all the scenarios that we consider we
manually decide to allow
such or such types of interactions to
reproduce what we observe in reality
and by summing all these scenarios we
obtain the desired probability
in string theory the approach is the
same however the particles are no longer
points
a point traces a trajectory over time
but a string traces a surface
and to describe the evolution of a
string in a probabilistic way as in
quantum physics
we will consider all possible geometries
that the string can trace over time
it can follow a specific trajectory
vibrate in a certain way
but also duplicate itself which amounts
to emitting a particle
or recombine which amounts to
reabsorbing the particle
forming a geometry with a hole
by summing up all possible geometries
string theory
automatically includes interactions
there is no need
to add them manually
incidentally interactions in the
standard model were local
the emission of a photon was
instantaneous for example
in string theory interactions are now
continuous
particles are no longer emitted
instantaneously
but gradually this gets rid of the
infinities
that we obtained when we tried to
include the graviton in the standard
model
in this way string theory not only
predicts the existence of the graviton
but it also allows us to calculate how
it interacts with other particles
and therefore to describe quantum
gravity
[Music]
so far the theory looks very promising
it explains why there are different
types of particles
it predicts that they can interact
and it includes a quantum description of
gravity
unfortunately at this stage the model
exhibits
three problems
first problem all the strings behave
like bosons
such as photons or gravitons
in our world there is another category
of particles
fermions such as electrons but
so far our model does not predict such
particles
second problem one of the particles
predicted by the theory
is what we call a tachyon its mass
appears to be an imaginary number
the square root of a negative number it
is a mathematical problem that we must
get rid of
finally the third problem our space time
has four dimensions
three dimensions of space and one of
time
but this theory only seems to work in a
universe
with 26 dimensions
at this stage string theory seems very
far
from describing our universe
to solve these problems we'll have to
push the theory
a little further to include fermions in
our model
the idea is to add spinners on the
strings
they are the mathematical ingredient
that already described fermions in the
standard model
by simply adding spinners to the strings
we solve two problems
the model now predicts the existence of
fermions
and it no longer predicts the tachyon
the particle that was problematic
this more complete theory is called
super string theory
in fact now that we added spinners our
theory exhibits a fundamental symmetry
between fermions and bosons in a way
it predicts that there would be as many
bosons as there are fermions
this is called supersymmetry
what about the third problem before we
included supersymmetry
the mathematics required a
26-dimensional universe
now superstring theory requires a
universe with
10 dimensions
[Music]
unfortunately this third problem is not
resolved
the theory does not seem to fit our
universe which only has four dimensions
yet so far the model was very promising
should we abandon it for all that
if they exist where would these six
missing dimensions be
one possibility is that our universe
could just be a three-dimensional slice
of a larger nine-dimensional universe
[Music]
another possibility could be that the
six dimensions that we do not
observe are curled up on themselves
to understand let's imagine an ant
walking on a straw
the straw has two dimensions the ant can
walk
back and forth and left to right
around the circumference of the straw
if we zoom out enough we only notice one
of the two dimensions
the second one that curls around the
straw is very small and cannot be seen
on this scale
in string theory we can assume a similar
phenomenon
our universe would have nine dimensions
of space
but six of them would be very small
dimensions curled up on themselves
so that we do not see them on our scale
this hypothesis may seem a little
far-fetched
is it reasonable to assume the existence
of dimensions that we do not observe
but it turns out that the existence of
additional dimensions is a very
interesting question
that suggests phenomena that we might
observe
for example we could imagine a massless
particle that moves at the speed of
light
but partially inside a compact dimension
[Music]
from our point of view we do not see
this dimension
and therefore the particles seem slower
to us
we only observe part of its full motion
it seems slowed down as if it had
a mass the idea of additional
compactified dimensions
thus suggests a fairly simple mechanism
through which some particles
might exhibit a large mass
however it would currently require too
much energy for us to create them in our
particle accelerators
and confirm or not their existence
the presence of these additional
dimensions also allows a much more
varied range of vibrational modes
and therefore a greater diversity of
potential types of particles
in addition there are a multitude of
different ways to curl up six dimensions
and each possibility will predict a
different universe
where the strings can adopt different
vibrational modes
and therefore behave like different
particles
by carefully choosing the way in which
these six dimensions are compactified
we can adjust our description so that it
predicts the same particles as those we
observe in
our world that said
among the myriad of possibilities it is
not yet clear why
our universe would contain the particles
of the standard model
rather than some other possibility
according to some still speculative
hypotheses the geometry of the universe
might even have varied over time
transitioning from one compactification
to another and the laws of physics could
thus have changed
during the first instance of our
universe
to conclude string theory remains to
this day
a speculative model very difficult to
test experimentally
since the strings would be incredibly
tiny
and which is only one approach among
many others
in the quest of finding the ultimate
theory
however it is still one of the most
promising models
whose insights have far exceeded its
original goals
strings allow us to describe gravity on
the quantum scale
and open doors to the study of black
holes
they help develop several fields of
mathematics
and get a better understanding of the
standard model itself
string theory even offers hypothetical
candidates for particles
such as axions to potentially explain
dark matter
that said there is still a lot of
research to do
in particular the aspects of string
theory that are best understood rely
heavily
on supersymmetry which tends to predict
the existence of additional particles
which we don't seem
to observe yet there are some
compactifications that would explain
that we don't observe supersymmetry
however these are still very rare and
not well understood
finally to venture even further there
actually exist
five different versions of superstring
theory
describing different types of universes
we can show mathematically that these
five theories
are in reality approximations of a
single
more complete model describing a
universe
with eleven dimensions m
[Music]
theory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you